pour cette seconde étape direction la
société à votre service traiteur
spécialisé dans le service de
restauration auprès des particuliers et
des entreprises jean-marc de nouer ses
équipes continuent de travailler malgré
la réduction de son activité
suivez moi je crois que son cuisinier
est en train de préparer des pigeons
pour la semaine prochaine c'est parti et
nous sommes avec jean-marc se noue
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le dirigeant
de la votre service traiteur société
intel créé il ya 15 ans alors on sait
que le secteur de la restauration est
frappé par ce second confinement comment
ça se passe pour vous et bien déjà nous
ça a été stoppée dès le couvre-feu nous
travaillons énormément avec les
entreprises et les particuliers dans
l'événementiel tout toute l'année là ça
totalement arrêtée on a une quinzaine
d'annulations des l'annnonce du
couvre-feu et quand est arrivé le
confinement
las tout s'est arrêté plus aucune
commande tout ce que j'en avais été
annulés donc il a fallu penser à faire
autrement on voit que vous avez quand
même un peu d'activité là où votre
cuisine et préparer des pigeons tout à
fait alors on a des clients on a la
chance d'avoir des clients fidèles
depuis 15 ans qu'ils nous ont demandés
de faire des petits menus pour les
anniversaires ou là entre autres pour un
anniversaire de mariage ils seront 3 et
vous demandez à un menu un petit peu
spécial on a donc préparé des pigeons du
foie gras que l'on va mettre à la carte
la semaine prochaine puisqu'on a mis en
place une carte de vente à emporter qui
va changer tous les mardis donc là dès
la semaine prochaine il y aura du pigeon
il y aura du foie gras pour les menus et
c'est là où vous avez inventé en quelque
sorte votre activité
parce que finalement vous êtes habitué à
travailler pour des particuliers des
entreprises plutôt dans l'événementiel
mais là vous allez devenir quasiment 1
restant à vente à emporter en fait c'est
ça on a l'habitude nous de d'avoir des
commandes quelques jours avant voire
quelques semaines avant d'avoir des
commandes pour vingt trente quarante
cinquante personnes
là je vous dis pour dimanche c'est pour
trois personnes demain on a des
plusieurs petites commandes de 2 3
personnes
c'est totalement se réinventer c'est
entre faire du 40 50 cents personnes et
faire deux par deux merci j'en ai besoin
non merci à vous
[Musique]